what's happening reject nation i am
going to react to the final episode of
the clone wars today
i've been on the edge of my seat for the
last few
episodes and then when i reached the
final episode which was just a couple
days ago
i was like i think i'm just gonna react
to it and put it up on youtube thank you
guys to everyone who's been encouraging
me to watch the show for the longest
time
mainly been watching it because i know
ahsoka tano's supposed to appear
in the mandalorian so i'm trying to get
all that knowledge and i know her final
appearance is actually in rebels
so i gotta somehow squeeze in some
episodes of rebels while i'm at it too
everyone was right everyone's been
telling me to watch the show for the
longest time it's a rad
rad sandwich of a time significantly
improved
a lot of the prequel experience in a lot
of ways i'll be putting up the full
length watch along where you sing it
with a time code at our patreon page
over there we cover a lot of shows where
we do watch alongs for them and then
there's many shows too most of them
where we have the option for reaction
highlights or watch long at the same
tier
as well so thank you everyone's been
checking us out over at our patreon page
highly encourage you to go over there
and i do got to interrupt this intro
because i tried many edits to get this
video up to prevent it from getting
blocked send it over to my buddy
eric over at nerdy chronic thanks so
much for all the editing you do
i don't know what you do that i don't
but you are gifted give him a follow
he's earned it he works his ass off
thanks again for adjusting for me so
last minute eric enough chit chat let's
watch this damn thing
this has been so intense i'm so late to
watching this show
damn
gosh you're so cool
oh i hope rex doesn't die did you
also escaped he didn't escape i let him
out
why diversion that's one word for it
man maul is so cool i wish we got to see
a live-action version of this kind of
mall
she's just been forcing his way out of
this whole time
[Applause]
oh
he's so cool
he really does everything like it takes
no effort
god damn look at him go
that is a hell of a shot start unlocking
the doors on bay 12.
prep the shuttle gg find out what
happened to this ship
man her faith in anakin is just so s
like
that really got to me we should start
reacting the episodes in the final four
episodes
[Music]
there it is
ah christ so what do we do
find our way to the shuttle mall's just
gonna show up there are too many
hook it up away this ship is going down
and those soldiers my brothers
are willing to die and take you and me
along with them
ah the wreck stuff is just so
heartbreaking
oh man you're a good soldier rex
so was every one of those men down there
ah this show
nailed it on the [ __ ] but i am not
the one who is going to kill them
so we're just going to surrender admit
defeat
[Music]
now while i don't see any
other option i have an idea
don't worry it's a good one sir
we think more might be headed your way
be aware hold your fire
i said hold your fire jessie i had the
situation under control
but there's aren't they uh order to kill
right away
yeah i will ah is no longer a jedi
hasn't been
oh she doesn't want to kill any of them
don't be a dick dope
god damn it jesse
you know you're really cool but you get
on my nerve sometimes right
jeez
oh wow
no i really don't want rex to die
oh
classic star wars shot
[Music]
wowie
oh she is so cool
oh so cool
[Music]
yeah you scum
oh no
man if ahsoka's faith would the jedi
order wasn't shaken enough as it is
wow look how awesomely shot this is
[Music]
it's a little a little bit of force to
your long way right now there you go
oh wow what a shot
i'm so sorry man what are like a
heartbreaking situation for for him to
be in
fascinating
huh i really don't know
the details of the rebels story so
that's nuts how we haven't cut back to
anakin and all this like they just let
revenge of the sith
take place
oh
oh is he gonna find her lightsaber
wow that's crazy this is weird to see
darth vader here
yeah oh
[ __ ]
do you feel anything at all
what a glorious shot
wow
i mean you know it's not the end of the
star wars story but in terms of
concluding
clone wars holy crap man those last few
episodes dude
those are nail biters it served that
that feeling
of any good prequel would do it's like
you know the clones eventually have
order 66 activated
and they're gonna turn bad but you've
spent so long caring about them and
getting invested in them you really
humanize them you see them as heroes
also anakin is really portrayed as a
strong hero in this series and then to
have that final shot with the
fall of the clones follow manik and
skywalker it's like they got revenge of
the sith to take care of the last bits
and pieces because this show explored so
much of the slow descent of anakin
skywalker that i love that they just
chose to keep it primarily focused on
ahsoka tano
a lot of wrecks too in this final season
i don't know where to begin man
yeah i'll just ask this right away who
was that bird i actually
uh i don't know who what that bird was
that uh is that just some
symbolism thing i don't know who that
bird is that was flying above darth
vader i feel like i should know
and i feel kind of bad for not knowing
but if you guys can clarify
that for me i'd really appreciate it
from the main takeaway of this episode i
don't know
if rex is in rebels or not to me
watching this my main concern was was
rex gonna die
you know you spend so much time with the
clones getting to know them than him
having to
go against not all the clones jesse at
the lead of it
by the way that's something that i
thought was really cool about seeing
order 66's influence on the clones minds
in the prequel movies they kind of
portray the clones sort of like they
were just
mindless drones to a certain extent even
when they were fighting on the
on the good side and then when they
turned they just kind of portrayed as
mindless germans what i thought was
neat here as you see in that scene when
rex is you know pretending to hold
ahsoka hostage and he's arguing with
jesse
that the chip doesn't just turn you into
i will kill they're not just terminators
they warp their beliefs they warp their
philosophies with such
conviction that it's the ultimate type
of brainwashing it's not
just i must kill it's not that scene in
terminator 3 rise in the machines where
arnold is trying to kill john carter you
know it's it's a completely different
thing their beliefs have been completely
changed that makes it even
more uh troublesome that makes it even
more weary on the heart
this is such a difficult position to be
in you know in the penultimate episode i
think it's called shattered
if i'm not mistaken rex and ahsoka are
talking to one another and rex
brings up this interesting type of
philosophical discussion
the war is confusing for them because
they were born
into this life they were born into this
war they don't
like the war they want the war yet if
the war didn't exist
they wouldn't exist he has such a big
heart and him and ahsoka's bond is one
of the joys of watching a lot of these
episodes
in this position you know this is his
family this is his family who he has to
go against so when they take off the
helmet and he's crying when he's trying
to convince ahsoka look they're gonna do
whatever it takes to kill you and
he knows that they're on the wrong side
here but it doesn't make it any easier
for him and i'm so happy they captured
that new one i mean
we wouldn't expect anything less at this
point but i'm so happy they captured
that nuance with the socatano
like her morals are just some of the
best
i have never been as good of a person
her moral high ground is just so so up
there
even in the face of all this i love the
fight scenes of when her and rex are
working together because he hasn't set
stun
she's using her force abilities she's
doing whatever she can
to not kill any of them that even
knowing
all they want to do is murder her she
knows it's not their fault
she still really cares about them and
she's doing her absolute best to make
sure she's not responsible
for murdering any of them even in the
face of having to defend her own
life and fight the good fight that was a
surprising ending when she puts out
lights i can see why she puts the
lightsaber down
order 66 everyone's being told to
execute but she like the one of the
lightsabers down i don't know the full
extent of what's supposed to
come after that or segway into rebels
when she does show up but basically i
was surprised
when she put it down because she only
puts one of them down and makes sense
with how she would be
someone who's gonna be hunted she has to
leave the past behind
from the way season six was going and
then going into season seven just at
this
conflict of should she become a jedi or
not she leaves the jedi order she's just
been at such
heavy conflict of this now she
officially does have to leave the past
behind
i guess i just wasn't expecting uh that
final moment and it's interesting
because i've obviously seen the
mandalorian before watching this show
and the first image i've ever seen
of like helmets of clones on spikes was
in the first episode of the mandalorian
which had this real
ominous dark like yeah put those
stormtroopers
heads on there here it's actually
heartbreaking
because none of this was their fault
they were programmed into this
brainwashed these are people that she's
fought alongside with
they've beaten many battles and those
are rex's brothers shattering and for
something that's tying in so
closely to revenge at the sith it's it's
playing and i'm kind of curious to know
if there's like a video i could watch
that has some type of timeline breakdown
of because i know
in in the last episode of order 66 is
initiated ahsoka and tomb of the force
starts to hear some revenge of the sith
going on
like that you're hearing the actual
dialogue brought into the show
i don't know what the exact timeline is
of of when all this big finale
was taking place because she's using the
force to listen and speaking of the
force that moment
where you know that played out way
better than it did
in the rise of skywalker or she
wall's trying to escape but she's using
the force then again it's that moral
code that she has where she decides to
let the ship go
let maul go i couldn't tell if maul was
feeling a little bit bad
there's something about his look that
was giving me the impression that there
might have been a
a hint of regret no no it's darth maul
so i highly doubt it but then she goes
to say
it's a fight with uh rex instead and
she's so awesome
and then she does a spin thing on the
floor and it's like in revenge of the
zip i thought it was really fitting
because so much of this
series explores you know explores a lot
and i gotta say i have i haven't seen
all of the show i mainly
started it just because i know ahsoka
tano's in mandalorian season two i had
someone help me out
to get a list of all the essential
viewing episodes
which has been a lot watch these getting
into uh season seven but it's not all of
the show i
um i probably should have mentioned at
the beginning of this video so i want to
go back and just kind of watch
all of it thinking about the time at
mortis with anakin
it being his destiny to bring balance to
the force you're watching this slow
descent of him
uh throughout this [ __ ] like a really
fleshed out slow descent
and by the way better romance than
anything from
episode two and three in this season you
don't really get much of anakin it's
it's actually not really necessary to
get that because you could just
watch revenge of the sith however it
tying in with darth
showing darth vader at the end of him
picking up ahsoka tana's lightsaber is
there a sense of
remorse that he's feeling in that moment
what is he feeling
there obviously this is after he learns
that padme is dead
no because of the fact that he has a
vader mask on here like i i don't know
what he's feeling exactly man i do
really love that last shot though of a
vader on his face and he's got that red
eye
peeking through so so intense i don't
recall in the movies him having the red
eye though
explain down below in the comments
there's kind of this ambiguous
ending that they have in a lot of ways
the shot of the the the
of darth vader walking away in the clone
visor helmet because when ahsoka and rex
were last there it hadn't become
all icy and frosted over and all snowy
so to get to this point some time has
passed meaning there's been some time
with
whatever vader's been doing with
palpatine during this time right so i'm
not sure exactly what that closing
moment
means but i feel like it's open to
interpretation to me the clones are not
bad but they both have this fault and
there's kind of a duality happening with
them and
after all this is not the anakin
skywalker show the ahsoka tana show it's
called the clone wars him walking away
as the ice is going over it like him
turning away from his past
ultimately how he fought alongside with
the clones more importantly
that's ahsoka's clone survey helmet so
it also represents him walking away from
ahsoka probably that's more what it
means now that i think about i don't
know why i wanted to go there first him
walking away from
everything in that moment which i do
find integral to
the arc of anakin skywalker as well
because you know we get revenge of the
sith fallout with obi-wan
he loses padme obviously turning his
back on the jedi order
his relationship with ahsoka was so
important it's not explored in the
movies obviously but in terms of
canon with star wars and who his
character is now it's a shot of him
officially walking away from her and is
there a name for that helmet that
redesigned the helmet it's really cool
to look it's a really cool helmet if i
was to buy a funko pop i'd probably buy
that they're a name for that one
i just in my mind i call it the socatano
clone trooper helmet my mind is a a
little bit
scattered at the moment and i'm shooting
him i hope i
made sense while i was talking there's a
part of me that's wishing i watched this
and then waited to
shoot the review part the next day but
as it stands it's pretty great it's
pretty grand stuff
uh i was i'm very much impressed with
the show and also the animation i
thought
they they really threw down for the
final season but i think in the last few
episodes they
really they really gave like top-notch
animation i'm not good at talking the
animation dialogue or i don't know the
lingo too well but it's one of those
things that just clearly registers of
this looks sharper this looks more
detailed ah
all right guys star wars the clone wars
finale
leave your thoughts down below what you
think who's your favorite character from
clone wars love to hear what you guys
say
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell tell me who that bird
is you can check us out on patreon if
you want last but not least
eric horstmann i just love the hell out
of this guy
talk to him pretty much throughout the
week due to recent events
with a certain presidential election he
made a promise
that if a certain somebody won
he would quit smoking so eric horseman
i hope you stick true to your word
sounds like after everything we've been
talking about that it's
probably a necessity right about now for
you to stop
you have a victory to celebrate i
suggest that you hone in on those
positive feelings and keep remembering
that and do your best to quit
and if you don't well at least you you
tried
do or do or do not there is no try
either way buddy regardless of whatever
choices you make in life just know
that as long as you're not intentionally
harming other people i'll always love
you
harm yourself as much as you you've been
a great friend you've been an amazing
supporter
can't wait to just continue this
friendship and then one day we will go
down to georgia
meet the devil himself
[Music]
you